[Music]
sometimes in a search for meaning
you could find yourself browsing in the
philosophy section of a bookstore
it's here where you might come across an
idea that changes your life
in kevin eulog's case he discovered an
idea that changed a lot of lives this
book really convinced me that i can and
should like try to make a big positive
impact
kevin is a 32 year old software
developer living in ottawa back in 2014
he came across this book by australian
philosopher peter singer
it paints a very emotional picture of
the plate of the extremely poor and then
it's like very concretely like here's
what you can do that will help them then
i became convinced that it was like
literally the correct thing to do like
this is the action that i should take
kevin now donates 25
of his income to charity for context the
average canadian gives less than two
percent but he's not donating this large
sum to just any charity kevin is part of
a growing global movement that uses
evidence and reason to figure out the
best way to do good in the world it's
called effective altruism
even though kevin had never consistently
donated to charity before he found
himself compelled to give
effective altruism introduced me to the
idea that like i can work my totally
normal job and still like give
ambitiously and make like a significant
impact
if we're going to live an ethical life
it's not enough just to not cheat steal
mime kill but that if we have enough we
have to share some of that with people
who have so little
that's peter singer
to make this point he uses an analogy
so
i ask you to imagine that one day you're
walking across a park
and in this park there's a pond
but you look at it and you do notice
that there is something in the pond
splashing around
and when you look closer you're shocked
to see that it's actually a very small
child
and the child seems to be drowning
you rush down to the pond as you do the
thought occurs to you damn i've just put
on my most expensive shoes because i'm
going to this important occasion
is this child really my responsibility
and he says most will agree you ought to
save the child even if it means you'll
ruin
your clothing anthony skelton teaches
moral philosophy at western university
if you can prevent something very bad
from happening like the loss of a life
without sacrificing anything of
comparable moral importance like your
own life
then you ought morally speaking to do it
he says you're in a similar relationship
to the global poor as you were to that
young child
effective altruism combines this notion
with the idea that one charity can be 10
to 100 times more effective than another
so you should give to charities that do
the most good for the most people so
it's really about sort of emphasizing
the sort of common adage of you know you
want to get the most bang for your buck
kevin started out by giving a few
hundred dollars to charities that give
out bed nets to prevent the spread of
malaria
now he donates tens of thousands of
dollars to organizations that prepare
for extreme famine and the next pandemic
causes considered high impact by
organizations like givewell
which evaluates and ranks charities
based on how many lives are saved
25 of your income is not insignificant
how has that impacted you and your your
lifestyle the main thing that i did to
increase my giving was that i
intentionally moved out of my one
bedroom apartment and moved in with
roommates so that i could have more
money to donate
so this is my room
in addition to downsizing he also became
a vegan animal welfare is another high
priority cause that effective altruists
care about
there's actually a method for how they
decide where to focus their efforts it's
called the itn framework which stands
for importance tractability and
neglectedness
so they just want to know is there a
neglected issue where they can produce a
lot of good and where we think if we do
take concrete steps we can really change
the effective altruism movement has
thousands of members worldwide including
around 400 in canada who have donated
hundreds of millions of dollars to
charities
the movement attracts everyone from
students to billionaires all of whom
pledged to give away at least 10 percent
of their income over their lives but
effective altruism isn't just about
donating money some effective altruists
have donated kidneys to strangers while
others like grishika bose plan to
dedicate their life's work to solving
big global problems i think i found out
about effective altruism
maybe when i was 15 i was trying to
figure out what was important to me and
what i wanted to do
just in general
initially rushika thought she might go
into physics because it's a subject she
enjoyed but then she discovered the
website 80 000 hours co-founder benjamin
todd encourages students to take high
impact careers rather than simply
following their passion
even if you match your passion with your
work and you're successful you can still
quite easily fail to have a fulfilling
career that's because you might not find
the work meaningful
that made me start thinking about do i
really just want to go into career doing
research in physics pursuing some
abstract
ideas that might not have any
application
will that
make me happy
or
is there something i could do where i
could make a difference
rashika is now finishing her degree in
cognitive systems at the university of
british columbia
she hopes to pursue a career in
artificial intelligence risk a field
popular among effective altruists and
once she gets a job she plans to donate
a portion of her earnings to effective
charities
i've always been brought up to try to
help people and to prioritize trying to
make the world a better place at least
in a small way
my mother is a doctor a pediatrician
she would always try to help the
children
around us in india when i found out
about ea which is not only about
altruism but about
effective altruism about trying to do
good as efficiently as we can
it
drew me in because
it just seemed to make so much sense
young people in cities and on university
campuses are attracted to effective
altruism
even as research shows younger canadians
are donating less than their parents did
at their age i wanted to speak to
someone about this so i reached out to
the person who started it all
peter singer
do you see effective altruism
as
a thing that's going to save the charity
sector by getting you know millennials
and gen zers involved in giving and
making that a part of their daily life
they don't want to go on
in traditional ways of giving charity
where essentially you hand them a
regular donation and you don't really
ask them what they're doing with it so
i think that is something that appeals
to younger people and that if we can get
the effective altruism message out more
widely we
will do something to restore
interest in charitable giving
you've advocated for various causes over
the course of your career animal rights
as well as global poverty
how is effective altruism given your
life meaning
i suppose i grew up with a with a sense
that it's really bad for them to be
suffering you know extreme suffering is
something that is really terrible i mean
that may be my family background because
my family went through the holocaust
some of them survived some didn't when
you can reduce that suffering and make a
difference
then you feel that you've lived your
life well but that you've done something
worthwhile and that's what
effective altruism has done for
me roshika is starting an effective
altruism club on campus and she says
there's already been a lot of interest
we're always told about all the problems
in the world
we're bombarded with news about it every
day as a teenager through social media
and this just feels like a way we can
really
take the problems head on
and feel like we're actually doing
something
and so when you find out that you can
like save an individual human life
uh that's like that's that's a lot it's
a big source of meaning for me now
the ideas of effective altruism seem at
odds with our culture today which is
more interested in the pursuit of
individual happiness and success
than in the search for meaning
the movement is perhaps a reaction to
that
a way for each and every one of us to
make the world a better place
one life at a time